die nasa will die reise von der erde zum
mars über einen zwischen posten im all
abwickeln dem deep space gateway eine
art umsteigebahnhof hinter dem mond der
viele vorteile mit sich bringt ende der
2030er jahre sollen die ersten menschen
dann von dort zum mars gelangen jetzt
der umfangreiche report zum thema in
zusammenarbeit mit technology review
am ende des videos haben wir eine
kostenlose ausgabe dieser wirklich sehr
spannenden zeitschrift für euch exklusiv
klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen erde mond mars so sieht die
geplante route zum mars mit dem umweg
über den mond nach den neuesten plänen
der nasa aus die vorteile des zwischen
postens im all
deep space gateway die sg liegen auf der
hand raumschiffe müssten beim abflug von
dort keine erdanziehung mehr überwinden
und würden so auf ihrer reise zum mars
weniger treibstoff verbrauchen
die nasa plant die raumstation nicht im
erd- orbit sondern hinter dem mond im so
genannten halo bitte heben sich die
schwer kräfte von erde und mond für
einen dritten körper auf so ließe sich
die raumstation relativ easy auf dieser
bahn halten ohne viel energieaufwand um
gegen gravitationskräfte anzusteuern ein
weiterer vorteil von hier aus ließen
sich auch die rückseite und die pole des
mondes erforschen was bisher noch nicht
wirklich passiert ist die einzelnen
etappen des projektes sind schon in
planung ab 2022 sollen die benötigten
module des die sg zum zielort gebracht
werden und zwar an bord der neuen
trägerrakete space launch system mit an
bord außerdem eine orion kapsel mit bis
zu sechs astronauten astronauten die die
module zusammensetzen und konfigurieren
eine weitere mission im jahr 2022 soll
auch das solarkraftwerk des dsg in den
halo orbit bringen
in den jahren darauf folgen dann das
habitat das logistik modul und eine
luftschleuse für die geplanten
außeneinsätzen läuft alles glatt wird
die station schon 2025 einsatzbereit
sein insgesamt sollen die drei module
des deep space gateways auf 50 tonnen
gewicht kommen deutlich kleiner also als
die ss die internationale raumstation
mit einer gesamtmasse von 450 tonnen und
15 modulen doch das ist kein problem
denn die neue raum basis soll weder eine
voll ausgestattete forschungsstation
beinhalten noch dauerhafte man sein
die geplanten missionen sind mit 60
tagen angepeilt der halo bild lässt sich
mit einfachen navigation season
anfliegen was auch in sachen
mondforschung äußerst positiv zu
bewerten ist dazu markus landgraf von
der esa dass die sg hat den vorteil dass
mit ihm auch kleinere raketen nachschub
zu einer mondbasis liefern können
wollte man nachschub direkt zum mond
bringen müsste man einen einschuss
manöver fliegen also vor dem mond
abbremsen um auf seiner umlaufbahn zu
landen
angedacht sind also wieder verwendbare
länder die zwischen der mondoberfläche
und dem dsc pendeln aber nicht nur das
das ds sie soll auch als
kommunikationsknoten benutzt werden und
zwar mit einer laserbasierten
datenverbindung schon 2013 hatte die
nasa die technologie getestet an leser
module auf einen forschungssatelliten
tauscht und dabei daten mit der erde aus
und zwar mit 600 megabit pro sekunde
heißt also ein skype gespräch zum mond
sollte locker drin sein dass die es sie
also als kommunikations und
verkehrskreuz für mondmissionen aber
eben nicht nur das denn es soll durchaus
auch als eine art testumgebung seien für
technologien die für eine mars-mission
gebraucht werden die ersten marsianer
sollen außerdem am dsg üben
selbstständig zu arbeiten und auch in
notfällen zu handeln denn auf einer
reise zum mars kann man nicht auf hilfe
von der erde hoffen die laufzeit der
kommunikationssignale von einigen
minuten sind dafür einfach zu lang um
eine lange reise zum mars zu ermöglichen
sind zudem neue triebwerks technologien
notwendig die nasa entwickelt ein
verbessertes hall triebwerk hier werden
gas zeichen elektrisch geladen und von
einem magnetfeld auf rund 100000
kilometer pro stunde beschleunigt die
triebwerke des dsc sollen dann auf bis
zu 15 kilowatt kommen die effekte
schubkraft ist mit 1,5 minuten super
kleinen zum vergleich das triebwerk
merlin 1d von spacex das in der welt
eingesetzt wird kommt auf einen schub
von fast einer million juden
dennoch reicht der geringe schuf völlig
aus für die geplanten manöver der dsg
solarzellen sollen den benötigten strom
liefern insgesamt 24 solarbetriebene
hall triebwerke und ein chemisches
triebwerk sollen dann auch
schlussendlich die raumfähre zum mars
antreiben die ab 2027 am gsg geplant ist
diese fähre besteht aus einem lande
modul einem antriebsmodul und einem
habitat bis zu 400 tage soll die
raumfähre damit bis zum mars braucht an
der gravitation des mondes sollen sie
schwung holen und dann mit dem horn
antrieb beschleunigen die raumfähre soll
bereits 2033 eine solche mission
bestehen erst einmal ohne passagiere bis
zu 1000 an der tage könnte dann die
darauffolgende bemannte mission dauert
der aufenthalt der astronaut und
astronautinnen auf dem mars ist bislang
mit 300 tagen angepeilt dafür benötigt
die raumfähre allerdings einen
ressourcen kreislauf für wasser und
sauerstoff ein vergleichbares system
testet die esa gerade im columbus modul
der iss hier wird wasser in sauer und
wasserstoff gespalten sauerstoff wird
der atemluft beigemischt und der
wasserstoff mit dem co2 aus der atemluft
zu methan und wasser umgewandelt das
methan kann als treibstoff gespeichert
werden oder aber im all entsorgt werden
und in einem bioreaktor gewinnen alten
aus den verbleibenden co2 sauerstoff
zurück ein kreislauf der tatsächlich
fast vollständig ohne zusätzlichen
sauerstoff auskommt eine weitere
herausforderung für den plan der nasa
ist die strahlung im all
sonneneruptionen und kosmische strahlung
gefährden hinter dem mond nicht nur die
bordelektronik sondern auch die
gesundheit der astronauten und
astronautinnen in besonderem ausmaß wie
soll man die neue raumstation und mars
fairen davor schützen sonneneruptionen
so wenn es lassen sich relativ präzise
vorhersagen so das equipment und
versorgungsgüter sicher gelagert werden
könnten und ein schutzanzug angezogen
werden könnte
doch warum der umweg über den mond wenn
eine bemannte mars-mission auch anders
funktionieren könnte erinnern wir uns an
die pläne von ihnen musk dem gründer von
spacex er will in den nächsten zwei
jahren eine gigantische rakete bauen die
big felkel rocket oder auch big fucking
rocket wie fa mit einer höhe von 160
metern von 2024 könnte sie nutzlasten
von bis zu 150 tonnen in den niedrigen
erdorbit bringen oder 100 menschen aus
dem orbit zum mars allerdings auch mit
zwischenstopp denn eine tankfüllung der
bfa erreicht nur bis in die
erdumlaufbahn
deswegen soll zunächst ein
treibstoffdepot in den r
wird gebracht werden eine bfa oberstufe
an die dann die zweite oberstufe
andocken kann und aufgetankt wird der
treibstoff für den rückweg vom mars zur
erde soll dann auf dem roten planeten
aus co2 und wasser hergestellt werden
alle ressourcen von spacex sollen in
dieses projekt gesteckt werden die
kosten werden auf bis zu 430 millionen
us-dollar geschätzt vielen dank an
technology review in zusammenarbeit mit
der redaktion dieser hammer zeitschrift
ist dieses video entstanden und
exklusive klicks und zuschauer
aber ich jetzt ein geschenk ihr bekommt
nämlich eine ausgabe gratis wenn er auf
diesen link klickt wenn ihr kein video
zu diesen dämon zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann hättet mich bei
whatsapp dafür einfach hier klicken und
am besten auch meine schwester canucks
und social media abonnieren das geht
hier und dann habe ich noch ein weiteres
spannendes video da geht es nämlich mit
weiter mondstation einzeln auf dem mond
entdeckt da geht's hier weiter bis dann
bleibt dran
[Musik]